we have a voicemail number that number
is
219 to david p um i
am uh causing concern among some of our
viewers
here is someone who's worried about me
take a listen to this hi david i just
watched and finished watching your video
right
um uh you did an interview with someone
with more subscribers
and i couldn't help but notice uh this
wasn't the key takeaway from the video
but
you seem that like be kind of uh pale
and have like
kind of like bags under your eyes i'm
just wondering if
if with of your newfound um success on
your
on your um channel uh maybe you've been
eating
too much magic spoon and it's been
keeping you up at night and you've been
using your
helix matrix more for things like
bluetooth and rest
yeah exactly no so i actually i got so
this is about an interview i did last
week
not from the studio but from the office
and then i received similar emails
this week because i've been broadcasting
from the bunker as we call it
no it people are used to the way i look
with my studio
lighting and that lighting is very very
powerful and professional and you know
there's six lights in there and
everything's tuned not perfectly but
it's tuned in a particular way
when people all of a sudden see me just
in front of like a white light
with you know a technical setup that's
not as not as properly balanced
including white balance
i often get messages david you're
looking very pale you're looking tired
the you know my real appearance is sort
of like the average of the way i look at
all of the different places i broadcast
from but everything's fine
i'm getting a good sleep i'm uh you know
taking my vitamin d
i'm doing all of my stuff everything's
fine i appreciate the concern but
absolutely no need to worry just
different lighting makes
i also got another one saying my voice
sounded strained this week
i'm just using a different mic it just
sounds different it's tuned a little bit
differently
the uh elements of audio are just
slightly slightly different than in the
studio so all is well
and i appreciate the concern on today's
bonus show ted cruz and josh hawley
two republican senators suddenly
they want to break up major league
baseball
is it because they've suddenly found
that we are not enforcing
antitrust law that is already on the
books
no it's just political they don't like
that major league baseball has protested
georgia voting restrictions
so they want to break up major league
baseball secondly
canada is doing a great job of reducing
poverty
and increasing equality we will talk
about how
they are doing it and lastly
uh we should be bracing for higher
grocery bills for the rest of the year
why and how much more expensive
we will talk about exactly that
on today's bonus show you can get
instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code
if you want the coupon code is better21
and it will save you
a bundle on a membership and also
finally it looks as though joe biden's
non-state of the union
state of the union has been scheduled
nancy pelosi sent a letter to joe biden
yesterday inviting him to
address a joint session of the house and
senate on
wednesday april 28th that's going to be
a big night we will be
live live live on youtube
twitch facebook we may even be live on
other platforms by then so
uh mark that on the calendar we will be
live on two weeks from today joe biden
will be doing his
it's not call the state of the union it
will be a joint address to the senate
and the house
that will be two weeks from today i'll
see you on the bonus show
i'll see you on the live stream and
we'll be back also of course
with a new show tomorrow